as you'll know the people running the
axis nations at the beginning of world
war ii
were not running them at the end of it
the notable exception being emperor
hirohito of japan
who despite thinking that bombing pearl
harbor was just a swell idea managed to
maintain his position as emperor of
japan for the rest of his life
but why why was hirohito allowed to stay
on the throne
well the most obvious answer is that it
made things easier unlike the other axis
leaders the japanese emperor wasn't just
some official
as emperor hirohito wasn't just admired
or liked by the japanese people but
revered and the allies knew that getting
rid of him would stiffen resistance
massively
except for stalin who didn't care and
was happy to continue even with the
extra fighting when japan sent out
feelers about conditionally surrendering
their condition was that the emperor
would remain in place
now the americans said no because the
allies had previously agreed that only
unconditional surrender would be
permitted
cleverly truman didn't explicitly state
to the japanese that they were going to
get rid of the emperor
just that japan would have the form of
government its people wanted
and given the emperor's popularity with
the people the japanese government saw
this as a guarantee that he would be
allowed to stay
it was not and after the emperor
accepted unconditional surrender his
position wasn't exactly secure
the american public wanted hirohito to
be tried as a war criminal and then
removed
yet for american leaders it wasn't so
simple the usa had several objectives
for the occupation of japan
one it wanted as little bloodshed as
possible and if keeping hirohito meant
that the japanese would lay down their
arms then that was fine
which brings me on to point two the us
government was concerned about communism
in japan and the imperial family was
seen as a bulwark against it
if japan had to be invaded it was almost
assured that the soviets would land as
well which would mean a divided japan
much like germany which was a no-no and
three
if the emperor was maintained then
reforming and occupying japan would be
much easier
since any new laws would be seen as
japanese mandates and not american
dictats
that's not to say that there was only
foreign pressure to remove the emperor
there were some more liberal-minded
ministers in government that believed
that japan needed a new start and a new
emperor
hirohito's son the americans were firmly
against this because it would look like
they had removed him and also because
the new emperor would be seen as a
puppet
which was an image that the americans
did not want because their long-term
plan was to make japan an ally in the
fight against communism
side note a job which was made much more
difficult when japan disbanded its armed
forces
making the americans fairly grumpy since
they now had to do all of the defending
in the end hirohito never saw trial and
remained on the imperial throne until
his tenure was cut short by a minor case
of mortality
and the reason for him remaining was
extremely simple pure expediency there
was no love between the american
leadership and the japanese emperor but
if the newly evolving american strategy
for the cold war was going to be a
success then the emperor had to stay
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly money maker the
pastry section marvin cassell rob
waterhouse mo
aaron the white james castaneda jordan
longley marcus arsenault gustav swann
jerry lambton john bailey spinning three
plates
rasheed ali cooling castleman david
silverman izzy
copper tone maggie paxkowski winston k
wood lexy schwinn spencer lightfoot
robert wetzel fortunate calf anthony
beckett and skye chappelle